RELEASE OF THE AFFIDAVIT.
BUT FIRST, NOW SINCE AUGUST 8TH,
THE DAY OF THE RAID ON
MAR-A-LAGO, THE END HAS BEEN
VERY CLEAR, TO AT LEAST HALF OF
THE COUNTRY THIS INVESTIGATION
APPEARS TO BE TAINTED BY
POLITICS.
NOW THE BELIEF ISN'T GROUNDED
AND SOME KNEE-JERK DISLIKE OF
THE RANK-AND-FILE FBI, BUT IT'S
RECENT HISTORY.
SPECIFICALLY THE CRUSADE WAGED
BY THE DEEP STATE AGAINST
DONALD TRUMP FROM 2015 AND
ONWARD.
A TWO-TIERED SYSTEM OF JUSTICE,
ONE STANDARD FOR HUNTER AND
HILLARY, AND ANOTHER FOR
DONALD TRUMP.
FAST FORWARD TO PRESENT DAY WHEN
DONALD TRUMP TOOK ANOTHER TURN.
THE U.S. MAGISTRATE REINHARD
BART OF JEFFREY EPSTEIN FAME,
HAD REDUCTIONS ON CERTAIN LINES
OF THE AFFIDAVIT WHICH THEN WILL
BE RELEASED TO THE PUBLIC
PERHAPS LATE NEXT WEEK.
VARIOUS MEDIA ORGANIZATIONS HAVE
PETITIONED THE COURT TO MAKE
PUBLIC THE FULL AFFIDAVIT
WITHOUT ANY REDUCTION.
BUT OF COURSE THE DOJ OPPOSED
THE AFFIDAVITS RELEASE MAKING
THESE BROAD CLAIMS AT RELEASING
EVEN LIMITED PARTS OF THE
AFFIDAVIT COULD CREATE DANGERS
FOR WITNESSES WERE FUTURE
COOPERATIONS AND ALSO REVEAL KEY
INVESTIGATIVE METHODS.
AND FOR OBVIOUS DRAMATIC EFFECT,
THEY DREW IN REFERENCE TO
NATIONAL SECURITY STAKES.
NONE OF THAT HOWEVER SEEMS
COMPELLING GIVEN WHAT IS AT
STAKE HERE.
THE PUBLIC STRIKES TO KNOW ALONG
WITH THE NEED TO ADDRESS
SKEPTICISM IN FAVOR OF RELEASING
THE ENTIRE AFFIDAVIT.
NO QUESTION IN DOING IT
IMMEDIATELY.
AND NOT JUST THE AFFIDAVIT, THE
SECURITY FOOTAGE AT MAR-A-LAGO
THAT WAS DETAINED AS WELL.
WE WANT TO SEE THAT.
DRAGON THIS ON TO THE MIDTERMS
WITH THE WITH THE DRIPS AND JOBS
BEING LEAKED IT TO KEY MEDIA
FIGURES WHO WE KNOW WHO THEY ARE
LIKE THE AMORPHOUS REFERENCES TO
NUCLEAR DOCUMENTS, THAT IS
DESIGNED TO DO ONE THING, TO
DISTRACT AND FRIGHTEN THE VOTERS
AS THEY HAD TO THE POLLS IN KEY
HOUSING SENATE RACES.
TO ME IT IS ALSO OBVIOUS AT THIS
POINT, NOW ON THE TRANSPARENCY
ISSUE, THE ANGLE IS PRETTY
SURPRISED THAT THE LEGAL TEAM
CHOSE NOT TO FILE ITS OWN MOTION
FOR A COMPLETE UNFEELING.
AARON BLAKE OF
"THE WASHINGTON POST" HAD THE
THEORY AS TO WHY SAYING SEEN THE
DOCUMENT REMAIN MOSTLY FIELD IS
PROBABLY BEST-CASE SCENARIO FOR
DONALD TRUMP.
HIS SUPPORTERS AND MANY
REPUBLICAN LAWMAKERS DECLARED
THE INVESTIGATION AS AN ABUSE OF
POWER BEFORE HAVING ANY
INFORMATION ABOUT IT LEARNING
WHAT PROMPTED IT ONLY FORCED
TRUMP AND ITS ALLIES TO ACCOUNT
FOR ACTUAL EVIDENCE.
WHILE, JOINING US NOW TO CLEAR
THINGS UP, CHRISTINA, THANKS FOR
BEING HERE TONIGHT.
YOU ARE IN COURT TODAY WHEN THE
MAGISTRATE RULED.
I'M CURIOUS ABOUT WHY YOU CHOSE
NOT TO FILE AN OFFICIAL MOTION
OR JOIN ANOTHER MOTION ARGUING
THIS AFFIDAVIT AS YOU GAVE IT A
DESIRE AS HE STATED IT FOR FULL
TRANSPARENCY.
>> HE DID SAY THAT, YOU'RE
EXACTLY RIGHT, WE BELIEVE THE
JUDICIAL OFFICE OF THE PARTY HAD
ARGUED QUITE WELL AND WE BELIEVE
IT WAS VERY INTERESTING AND
ENCOURAGING THAT YOU HAD PARTIES
FROM BOTH SIDES OF THE AISLE OF
COURSE OUTLETS COUPLED WITH
CONSERVATIVE LIFESTYLE GROUP
TOGETHER ON THE SAME SIDE.
AND SEE HOW THAT PLAYED OUT
RESERVING THE RIGHTS TO TRY
SOMETHING ELSE IN THE FUTURE,
AND REALLY JUST CHOSE TO SEE HOW
IT WILL PLAY OUT.
>> Laura: I UNDERSTAND THAT
YOU CHOSE TO DO THAT, BUT I'M
WONDERING, ARE YOU NOT CONCERNED
THAT BECAUSE YOU DID NOT JOIN
ANY OF THESE MOTIONS FOR AGAIN
THE FULL RELIEF OF THIS
AFFIDAVIT THAT YOU ARE THEN
WAVING POSSIBLE OBJECTIONS TO
THE WAY REDUCTIONS ARE BEING
DONE BY THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
LATER ON, BECAUSE HE DID NOT
SPEAK TODAY NOR DID YOU JOIN ANY
OF THESE MOTIONS AND THEY WILL
REDACT ALL OF THIS STUFF AND AM
NOT SURE WHAT GROUNDS YOU ARE
GOING TO HAVE AT THIS POINT
HAVING WAIVED YOUR RIGHT TO FILE
THOSE MOTIONS.
>> WE WOULD MAINTAIN THAT WE
HAVE NOT WAIVED OUR RIGHT TO
THAT THAT IS STILL MAINTAINED.
WE NEED TO WAIT AND SEE.
I CAN BE CERTAIN AT THIS POINT,
BECAUSE WE HAVE NOT SEEN THE
AFFIDAVIT AND CERTAINLY HAVE NOT
SEEN THE REDUCTIONS AND HOW IT
WILL PLAY OUT, BUT WE WILL BE
MAKING THAT DECISION AS IT COMES
OUT.
YOU KNOW, WE HAVE TO SEE IT.
WE HAVE NOT SEEN IT AND IT HAS
BEEN UNDER SALE, SO I DON'T
KNOW.
WE CAN'T SAY.
>> Laura: WELL, THE
SPOKESPERSON FOR
PRESIDENT TRUMP, TAYLOR BUDDHA
WHICH I BELIEVE SPOKE OUT TODAY
AND YOU KNOW, MADE ANOTHER
COMMENT.
YES, ABOUT HOW THE DEMOCRATS
HAVE A PENSION FOR USING
REDUCTIONS TO ACTUALLY HIDE THE
GOVERNMENTS DECEPTION AND
CORRUPTION JUST LIKE THEY DID
WITH THE RUSSIA HOAX, SO HE IS
OBVIOUSLY CONCERNED ABOUT THIS.
>> YES, THAT IS A CONCERN.
AND CERTAINLY THE JUDGE GIVING
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
BASICALLY CARTE BLANCHE
OPPORTUNITIES TO REDACT HOWEVER
THEY WANT TO WITH WHATEVER THEY
WANT TO, IT IS A CONCERN.
I THINK THAT IS IF YOUR CONCERN
AND SOMETHING THAT WE WILL HAVE
TO DEAL WITH AND FIGURE OUT AS
IT COMES OUT AND AS WE SEE WHAT
HAPPENS.
>> Laura: ON THE ISSUE OF THE
FOOTAGE OF WHERE THE DOCUMENTS
WERE STORED, MUCH IS BEING MADE
OF THIS FOOTAGE THAT'S WAS
ACTUALLY SUBPOENAED BY THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT, DO YOU HAVE
ANY INSIGHT INTO WHAT THEY CLAIM
WAS SOME BIG CONCERN ABOUT
THIS --
WHAT THEY UNDERSTOOD TO BE
SECURE AREAS SUCH THAT IT WOULD
JUST SEND THIS NINE HOUR RATE OF
MAR-A-LAGO?
>> I HAVE NO IDEA WHY THEY WERE
PARTICULARLY CONCERNED ABOUT IT.
THEY HAD COME OUT, THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE AND THE
FBI HAD SEEN IT FIRSTHAND AND IN
PERSON.
AND THEY KNEW EXACTLY WHAT IT
WAS AND WHERE IT WAS AND HOW IT
WAS SECURED, AND SO, THE IDEA
THAT THEY NEEDED TO READ IT TO
SEE IT AGAIN AFTER
PRESIDENT TRUMP HIMSELF HAD TOLD
THEM, YOU'RE WELCOME TO COME
BACK IF YOU FEEL THE NEED TO
COME BACK, SO, I THINK THAT IT'S
A BIT DISINGENUOUS AND TYPICAL
OF LEFTIST MEDIA TO COME UP WITH
SOME SALACIOUS STORIES THAT DO
NOT MAKE A LOT OF SENSE AND THE
PEOPLE SCRATCHING THEIR HEAD
WONDERING WHAT IS GOING ON, JUST
HOPING THAT IT WILL PASS.
>> Laura: SORRY TO INTERRUPT,
WAS THERE A LIMITED NUMBER OF
PEOPLE WHO HAD ACCESS TO THAT
STORAGE ROOM?
IT SEEMS LIKE A PRETTY IMPORTANT
ROOM AS THEY MADE SUCH A BIG
DEAL OF IT AND HAVE A LOCK ON IT
AND SO FORTH, WAS THERE A
LIMITED NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO
COULD GO IN AND OUT?
>> YES, CERTAINLY MAR-A-LAGO IS
SECURE AND IT OF ITSELF, JUST
GETTING ON TO THE COMPOUND IS
HARD.
AND THEN IT WAS A LOCKED THE
DOOR AND GETTING BACK DOWN INTO
THE BASEMENT THERE IS SECURITY.
YOU CAN'T JUST WALK DOWN THERE.
ONLY CERTAIN MEMBERS OF STAFF
CAN GET THERE AND THERE IS ONLY
ONE KEY.
SO YES, IT IS A VERY LIMITED
NUMBER OF PEOPLE THAT HAVE
ACCESS DOWN THERE.
AND IT WAS ENOUGH TO WHERE OUR
TEAM BELIEVED THAT IT WAS
SECURE, NOT THAT THEY ASKED FOR
ONE MORE LOCK AND ANOTHER LOCK
WHICH WE DID AND THEN FOR
WHATEVER REASON THEY EXCITED
THAT THEY STILL NEEDED TO RAID
THE PLACE.
>> Laura: AND ONLY ONE OR TWO
PEOPLE HAD ACCESS TO THAT ROOM
TO YOUR KNOWLEDGE?
>> THAT IS MY UNDERSTANDING.
I WOULD HAVE TO CHECK WITH THE
MAINTENANCE OF THE AREA, BUT
IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING IS A VERY
SMALL NUMBER THAT GOT IN THERE.
>> Laura: ARE YOU NOW ASKING
THE COURT I BELIEVE TODAY I READ
THAT YOU GUYS ARE ASKING FOR
THAT FOOTAGE TO ALSO BE
RELEASED, AM I CORRECT ON THAT?
>> I WOULD HAVE TO DOUBLE CHECK
ON THAT, BUT I THINK THEY ARE
COMFORTABLE WITH THAT, YES.
>> Laura: THAT IS A LOT OF
HOURS OF FOOTAGE TO RELEASE.